pick one word
if you want to make better business
decisions if you want to bring on better
employees if you want your customers to
spread the word about you
then pick one word that defines the
values that your business stands for
so it's easy for everybody to understand
what it is that you do and spread the
message
otherwise people will be confused and it
makes decision making hard and makes
bringing on new employees hard it makes
it hard for your customers
to talk about you
which is so important when you're first
starting up a business
i got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers khaled and i guess i had
mentioned this in one of my videos and
he wrote in great video my business
helps unleash the hidden potential
within kids i have a passion for this i
provide kids with something that's not
taught in our schools how can you put
this into one word
finding your one word is really tough
and really at the end of the day only
you can do it because it's got to be
something that you passionately believe
in you should read that word and it
should start making your heart jump it
should start getting you excited
so maybe it's something around kids
maybe it's about passion maybe it's
about potential maybe it's about
unleashing maybe it's about something
hidden or it was a totally different
word
you've already done a great job and turn
it into one sentence
now i try to combine that
and condense it even further down
but only you can really come up with
that word
and maybe would help us is to share how
i
come up with mind so my word is belief
and it took a long time
to get to that word of belief and i've
been in business for a number of years
and it's always been i've always
believed in entrepreneurs i've always
helped entrepreneurs and i haven't
changed
but the type of company that i've built
has changed and the way people talk
about me has changed and it's much more
in line with what i do
because i made it easy for them
to spread the message
so
i believe in entrepreneurs
if i'm bringing on somebody new to my
team you better believe in entrepreneurs
i don't care if you're the most gifted
programmer graphic designer copywriter
whatever it is if you're coming on board
you have to believe in entrepreneurs
otherwise you're out
if i want my customers to talk about me
they are because they believe in what
i'm doing
if i'm creating new products or creating
new content
then it has to help entrepreneurs
believe in themselves more or help their
customers believe in them more
it makes decision making
so much easier and helps people spread
the message about you so much faster
when you have one word that stands for
something that can create a movement and
get people excited
how i actually went about finding my
word was i started
i started thinking about all the
different things that that i did believe
in the things that
made me different the things that i felt
were core to me
and you want to think about things that
are totally outside of business
this is what you stand for as a person
because no matter what business you
start
you're still going to bring these core
values with you
so for me i wrote down things like
helpful
and helping i like i like helping people
i happen to apply that to entrepreneurs
but i love helping people in any
business i start
would would involve helping people
because that's what i'm all about
believe just seemed to resonate with me
more
and so i ran with that and all the
content that i provide i try to make
sure it's uplifting right it's still
it's still truthful it can still be raw
it can still hurt
but it's meant to build you up it's
meant to make you believe in yourself
and to believe that what you're doing is
possible and believe that that you're
doing the right thing
and so that word means something to me
and it means something to the people who
join my team and it means something to
the people who interact and watch these
videos and chime in on the website and
tweet me up on online and
i'm creating a group of people who share
the same value system as i do
and so you want the same thing for your
business and i can't tell you what that
word is i can only encourage you to
follow the same exercise i did
of writing different thoughts and
different words down on paper
until you find the one
that really hits you and when i first
saw believe i really liked it
i thought i would go with it but i said
you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna take
the night i'm gonna sleep on it and i
looked at the list again the next day
and i still loved it
and then from that day forth everything
had to change in my business everything
became about belief
and it's become much more powerful as a
result
so when you're creating your one word
remember that it's not related to your
business
it's something that is core to you
that you will take
in any circumstance that you go to in
any business that you start in any job
that you would take
you're bringing that core value and you
want to see it in every customer and
every employee that works with your
business when you can do that
it makes it so much easier to make good
decisions to bring on the right people
to bring on the right customers and for
customers to spread the word about your
business
believe
for those of you watching you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up i'd
also love to hear what you have to think
if you want to leave a comment under the
video i really appreciate seeing those
come in they really do make my day every
day when i check them so thank you and
i'll see you on the next episode